[Musik]
mein heutiger gast hamed abdel-samad ist
gebürtiger ägypter
er lebt seit inzwischen 26 jahren in
deutschland und ist inzwischen auch
deutscher staatsbürger
hinter ihm liegt ein bemerkenswerter weg
vom islamistischen muslimbrüder zum
islam kritiker herzlich willkommen bei
felix persönlich hallo danke für die
einladung
sie haben nicht nur zahlreiche
islamkritische bücher geschrieben
sondern auch dieses aus liebe zu
deutschland
warum titelt ein migrant aus liebe zu
deutschland weil deutschland ein sehr
liebenswürdig island ist das übrigens im
ausland viel beliebter ist als im inland
die ausländer die anderen länder liebe
in deutschland mehr alles die deutschen
ihr land
und weil ich mich auch mit der
geschichte dieses landes identifizieren
kann mit den vielen brüchen
es gab immer zwei wörter die mich mit
deutschland verbunden haben die auch den
heilungsprozess von deutschland und den
lernprozess von diesem land beschreiben
selbstüberschätzung selbstverantwortung
und selbstüberwindung ich habe im
wörterbuch geschaut ich es gibt für das
wort selbstüberwindung keine übersetzung
es gibt wunderbare deutsche wörter und
verliebt habe ich mich auch in die
deutsche sprache mir gefiel wie
deutschland auch deutschland hat einen
sehr bemerkenswerten weg hinter sich vom
heiligen römischen reich zum deutschen
nationalismus zu zum dritten reich zu
einer demokratie und wohlstand
gesellschaft ein land dass sechs
millionen juden vernichtet hatte aber
jetzt seine grenzen für verfolgten und
für kriegsflüchtlinge auch öffnet dieser
prozess ist sehr bemerkenswert und
deutschland und ich wir sind uns sehr
ähnlich
mit allen diesen brüchen
mit den lernprozess und mit der öffnung
für die westlich demokratische
demokratie das waren nicht immer bei mir
der fall wie sie geschrieben haben
das war auch für deutschland nicht immer
der fall jetzt haben ja deutsche
intellektuelle in aller regel ein
problem sie so vorbehaltlos zu
deutschland bekennen wie sie das machen
mit dieser satz aus liebe zu deutschland
ich erinnere mal an gustav heinemann der
hat gesagt ich liebe keine staaten ich
liebe meine frau ja ich glaube die
deutschen insgesamt oder viele deutsche
und vor allem die intellektuelle vor
allem auch die linksliberale
intellektuellen haben ein problem mit
deutschlands liebe weil natürlich dieses
schuldbewusstsein für die moderne
deutsche identität eine zentrale rolle
spielte jedes land braucht ein
gründungsmythos zu einem fixpunkt in der
geschichte an dem man seine identität
auf baut sein wertesystem und leider
konzentriert man sich sehr in
deutschland auf das unheil das zwischen
33 und 45 passiert ist und bau darum
herum eine identität ich bin davon gfrei
befreit obwohl ich verantwortung für die
geschichte auch deutschlands mit trage
aber kein schuldbewusstsein sondern
verantwortungsbewusstsein
das ist sehr wichtig für mich und ich
bin der meinung alles was auf schulbau
währt nicht lange sondern ruft
widerstand abwehr und aggressionen
heraus schuld ist die andere seite der
medaille der aggression und wir haben in
deutschland leider einige generationen
mit schuld geimpft sozusagen oder
initiiert in der hoffnung dass sie sich
jetzt von radikalen gruppen abwenden
aber ich befürchte dass das gegenteil
ist eingetreten
sie sagen sogar deutschland braucht ein
positives nationalbewusstsein was
verstehen sie denn darunter sicherlich
nicht nationalismus sondern einfach
selbstbewusstsein
das nation deutschland kann auf viele
schöne sachen in seiner geschichte aber
auch in der gegenwart stolz sein
jeder gesellschaft für geborene deutsche
braucht man eine positive identität die
sie inkludiert umarmt und die sie nicht
mit skepsis gegen sich selbst injiziert
auch migranten die herkommen wie können
migranten sich mit deutschland
identifizieren wenn deutschland auf sich
selbst so skeptisch und ablehnend
irgendwie blickt das geht gar nicht
soll das denn heißen dass sie meinen es
müsste ein schlussstrich gezogen werden
und die deutsche
vergangenheitsaufarbeitung nein also ich
genauso wie ich gegen diese
mystifizierung des bösen als fixpunkt
der deutschen geschichte bin ich auch
gegen eine schlussstrich nein eine eine
lebende lebendige erinnerungskultur ist
wichtig eben nicht mit schuldbewusstsein
sondern mit verantwortungsbewusstsein
wir verstehen was passiert wird tun
alles dass sich das nicht wiederholt
aber wir müssen nicht dabei immer
gepackt sein wird immer gebückt ist kann
seine arme für andere nicht öffnen um
sie zu umarmen um sie auf augenhöhe zu
begegnen sehr spannendes thema reden wir
gleich noch weiter über diese liebe zu
deutschland aber ich würde zunächst mal
noch gerne einen blick auf ihre wirklich
bemerkenswerte biografie werfen weil das
vielleicht ja auch vieles erklärt ich
habe erwähnt sie wurden in ägypten
geboren ihr vater war im arm das ist
also ein islamischer rechtsgelehrter
islamischer prediger was hat er ihnen
beigebracht hat mir den koran
beigebracht die etwas über die
ägyptische geschichte auch aber leider
auch dass ein teil meiner identität hass
gegen juden und christen sein muss
die andersartigkeit der anderen an der
skepsis gegenüber die anderen
er hat mir auch beigebracht war dagegen
dass ich in deutschland studiert hat
gesagt du wirst gescheitert zurückkommen
diese leute sind kaltblütig sie können
dich nicht verstehen und sie brauchen
dich auch in ihrem land nicht und das
war für mich eigentlich eine last aber
später auch eine motivation ist in
deutschland so schaffen sie waren als
student in kairo sogar bei den
muslimbrüdern wie sah denn damals ihr
weltbild aus ja ich will ich verließ
mein dorf und wollte in kairo einen
neuen weg finden ich wollte nicht ein
imam wie mein vater werden sondern
wollte literatur und sprachen studieren
und dort habe ich eigentlich eigentlich
meine erste sinnkrise oder sogar
identitätskrise und die muslimbrüder
haben mir so politischer teilhabe
sie haben für mich eine gemeinschaft
geborgenheit angeboten
und das war am anfang eigentlich sehr
spannende sehr schön teil eines
projektes zur reform reformation von
ägypten usw aber später natürlich habe
ich festgestellt dass sie genauso
diktatorische warten wie mubarak damals
wie war es dann als student nach
deutschland kam war das liebe auf den
ersten blick oder eher schmerzhaft es
war schmerzhaft dass diese liebe ist
wirklich gewachsen wie eine langjährige
beziehung nur am anfang hat deutschland
mich eigentlich entlarvt hat mich vor
mich selbst nackt gezeigt und die
meisten menschen wollen die wahrheit
über ihre kultur nicht sofort ist sie so
hat situation jeden tag ich bin nicht
gewohnt gewesen selbstkritisch so seien
hier die deutschen waren sehr neugierig
sie haben mich über schmerzhafte fragen
über meine religion über meine kultur
warum dieses wunderbare land ägypten aus
der pharaonenzeit jetzt eigentlich arm
und diktatorisch regiert wird und auch
islamistisch beeinflusst und ich und ich
hatte keine antworten darauf ich
blockierte und ich hielt die deutschen
eigentlich für gefährlich ich erinnere
mich ich habe damals ein film mit einem
freund gesehen leben des brian
wo eigentlich die geschichte jesus
einfach so komisch behandelt wird
satirisch und ich hatte angst ich hab
gesagt diese leute für sie ist nichts
heilig
sie gehen mit ihrer hat mit ihr den
heiligenfiguren zu um dann werden sie
eigentlich wie werden sie mit meinen
propheten oder meiner religion umgehen
und ich hatte zuerst angst habe
blockiert und bin zurückgezogen wie
wurde dann aus dem muslimbruder ein
islamkritiker ich ging danach nach japan
um dort zu studieren und habe gemerkt
dass die gleichen mechanismen sich in
japan in wiederholen obwohl ist eine
ganz anderes land ist
ich war sauer dass die japaner mich
nicht nach ägypten gefragt haben mich
nicht nach meiner religion gefragt haben
die diskussion im wein flach und ich
habe mich dabei ertappt deutschland zu
vermissen
die debattenkultur die damals eigentlich
sehr gesund war
im gegensatz zu heute und alles sich
nach deutschland kam da habe ich eine
entscheidung getroffen ich habe mich
entschieden deutscher zu werden und mir
war bewusst um deutscher zu werden muss
ich mich von teilen meiner kultur
trennen die gegen die freiheit und gegen
das zusammenleben in deutschland sich
richtung ich musste mich von konzept vor
der scharia vom dschihad
ich musste die gleichberechtigung von
mann und frau ohne wenn und aber
anerkennen und das ist für mich der weg
zur integration integration beginnt mit
einer entscheidung und den wunsch auch
teil dieses landes so werden jetzt ja
erwähnt sie haben zahlreiche kritische
bücher geschrieben über den islam ich
erwähne da jetzt mal stellvertretend
zwei titel
ein titel heißt mohammed eine abrechnung
ein anderer titel lautet der islamische
faschismus was stört sie denn so stark
am islam dass sie solche titel wählen
mich stört dass der islam fast alle
bereiche des lebens von muslimen
beeinflusst
ich lebe heute unter polizeischutz weil
der islam in mich ein häretiker sieht
und weil islamischer gelehrter live im
fernsehen in ägypten zu meiner ermordung
aufgerufen haben
mich stört eigentlich wollte ich gar
nicht ich habe ägypten verlassen und ich
wollte in freiheit leben aber der islam
verfolgt mich überall auch verfolgt
viele frauen wenn sie zu friseursalon
und gehen wollen da habe der islam da
eine meinung was sie essen was sie
trinken was sie anziehen was sie sich
wie sie sich auf die toilette verhalten
müssen also der islam ist sich ein in
allen bereichen des lebens und da gibt
es schon fast faschistoide züge also
dieser der glaube an die absolute
wahrheit
der prophet alles ein heilsamer heiler
und unfehlbar auch das gute konzept von
dschihad ist ähnlich wie im faschismus
im faschismus kämpft man nicht um zu
leben sondern man lebt um zu kämpfen und
im dschihad ist es genauso dschihad ist
eine sehr wichtige sache
verschwörungstheorien antisemitismus da
gibt es da viele parallelen zwischen
islamismus und faschismus
jetzt wird ja immer gesagt man muss klar
unterscheiden zwischen islam und
islamismus machen sie das auch oder
sagen sie das was sie kritisieren steckt
nicht nur ist nicht nur ein
islamistische missbrauch sondern das
steckt auch im islam drin
der islamismus ist die konsequente
politische umsetzung des islams der
islam ist politisch geboren anders als
das christentum war mohammed 23 jahre
lang auf der politischen bühne er war
nicht nur profit sondern er war armee
führer staatsmann war finanzminister und
hat sich um alle belange des lebens der
muslime
gekümmert und ich unterscheide lieber
zwischen islam und muslimen nicht jeder
moslem ist koran auf zwei beinen
die meisten muslime eigentlich beten
nicht fünf mal am tag die meisten
muslime ziehen nicht in den dschihad und
diese unterscheidung ist für das
zusammenleben wichtig aber der islam und
islamismus ist wie alkohol und
alkoholismus es kommt auf die dosis an
wie viel islam konsumiere ich im alltag
daraus wird entweder islamismus oder ein
private glaube sie haben das ja erwähnt
es gibt diese fatwa die gegen sie
ausgesprochen wurde
wie halten sie das aus seit jahren
können sie sich nur unter polizeischutz
bewegen
genau gesagt seit acht jahren wenn ich
zum bäcker gehe dann habe ich sechs
beamte an meiner seite das ist
unerträglich klar
und das ist leider ein ergebnis des
islamischen faschismus dass es gibt
heutzutage in der welt nur wenige sorten
von autorin die in gefahr leben das sind
autoren die die mafia kritisieren oder
vielleicht hat ihm ein puten manchmal
oder den islam
das ist kein gutes zeugnis für eine
religion die sich religion des friedens
nennt trotzdem denke ich frei und ich
glaube dass ich viel freier bin als
diejenigen die mich bedrohen weil ich
werde nicht von einem gedanken besessen
der mich irgendwie fern bewegt ich habe
meine gedanken ich kann meine gedanken
verändern wie menschen wir sind in
saalfeld von gedanken warum sollten wir
nur eine pflanze daraus nehmen und sagen
das sind wir wir sind das feld selbst
ich habe versprochen wir kommen noch mal
zurück auf diese liebe zu deutschland
dem buch haben sie den untertitel
gegeben
ein warnruf sie sagen unsere demokratie
und unsere freie gesellschaft ist in
gefahr wieso das
in teilen der deutschen gesellschaft
habe ich so was wie eine untertanen
mentalität entdeckt dass die auf das
neue jahrhundert zurückgeht alles der
deutsche bildungsbürger eigentlich alles
hatte er hat gutes jahrhundert im 19
jahrhundert ja im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
da hatte da der deutsche bildungsbürger
alles gute wirtschaft gute bildung
kultur sogar qualitätszeitung alles
mögliche aber keine politische teilhabe
er zog sich zurück und beugte sich vor
dem fürsten oder vor dem könig und
dieser mentalität setzt sich fort dass
das gab es im dritten reich das dritte
reich hat von dieser mentalität sehr
profitiert und das jetzt auch im
politischen spektrum der ziehen sich
viele menschen aus der politischen
diskussion zurück entweder aus angst als
nazis beschimpft zu werden oder eben
weil sie erwarten dass die da oben alles
machen und da haben wir zwei sorten von
untertanen bürger der sogenannte
wutbürger der mit nichts zufrieden ist
und erwartet dass die regierung da oben
alles für ihn in ordnung bringt oder der
unsichtbare bürger der nur alle vier
monaten mal in erscheinung tritt um
politische mehrheiten zu sichern und
dann zieht er sich wieder zurück und
nimmt an diese diskussionen nicht das
ist ein punkt der andere punkte wofür
ich warne ist die meinungsfreiheit die
wir zentimeterweise in deutschland
verlieren mit dieser unglaublichen
identitätspolitik in den die politik ist
eigentlich eine gute idee
nichts ist verwerfliches daran sich für
minderheiten einzusetzen für
gleichberechtigung von unterdrückten
oder benachteiligten gruppen
das ist wunderbar aber wenn daraus eine
ideologie wird dann wird es
problematisch und hier kommt wiederum
parallele zum islamismus bei der politik
und islamismus blicken auf den menschen
nicht als individuum sondern als
vertreter eine gruppe beide wollen die
gesellschaften umerziehen weiter haben
eine gefährliche politische correctness
die die meinungsfreiheit gefährdet und
beide halten viel von dogmen alles von
der freiheit und von vernunft geht es
ihnen denn dabei persönlich viele
greifen jahren und sagen das was sie da
am islam kritik äußern das ist in
wirklichkeit islamophob und sie spielt
afd in die hände
das ist genau ein teil dieser
identitätspolitik wenn ich jemand ernst
nehme dann kritisiere ich ehrlich dann
sage ich meine meinung ehrlich nein ich
finde die ideen des politik spielt afd
in die hände
wenn wir wichtige debatten wie migration
islam auch crooner politik nicht ehrlich
und auch kontrovers diskutieren dann
wenn alle diese firmen aus der mitte der
gesellschaft verschwinden universitäten
trauen sich nicht mehr über solche
themen zu diskutieren
politische stiftung ziehen sich zurück
das ist eine normale entwicklung des dfb
das thema für sich entdeckt entdeckt und
sich alles verteidiger der vielfalt der
meinungsvielfalt und meinungsfreiheit
was sie eigentlich nicht sind ich würde
mal interessieren wo sie die die die
grenzen der diskussion der debatte und
der meinungsfreiheit sind
reden sie mit jedem reden sie auch mit
der afd
ich habe kein problem mit irgendjemand
zu sprechen ich höre dir mit den grünen
ich rede mit cdu mit spd warum auch
nicht mehr da dachte ich habe mit dfb
gesprochen und habe die afg kritisiert
bei der afd
das ist mein auftrag ich bin ein freier
mensch ich habe nicht ägypten verlassen
um hierher zu kommen um mir vorschreiben
zu lassen mit denen er trete ist du dich
und mit denen redest du nein ich rede
mit
und ich sage meiner meinung mein
standpunkt ist humanismus aufklärung und
ein weg ich will einen weg finden
miteinander zusammen zu leben
diejenigen die sich weigern mit der fdp
zu sprechen was bieten sie an
lösen sie das problem zum beispiel das
problem des rassismus oder wollen sie
nur empörung schüren wollen sie nur sich
politisch profilieren ich alle
schriftsteller muss mit jedem sprechen
mir selbst ein bild machen und darüber
transparent und ehrlich in meine bücher
darüber schreiben sie haben gerade das
stichwort geliefert rassismus das ist
das thema ihres neuesten buch ist das an
diesem wochenende erscheint und da kann
man gerade an diesem thema finde ich
sehr schön diese frage was sollte man
sagen was sollte man besser nicht sagen
thematisieren aber zunächst mal
sie sind ja als migrant nach deutschland
gekommen haben einen namen der bisschen
anders klingt welche erfahrungen mit
rassismus haben sie denn selber in
deutschland gemacht
ich habe einige erfahrungen mit
rassismus gemacht übrigens auch in
ägypten in meinem land nicht wurde
rassistischen der in ägypten angegriffen
weil ich als kind helle haut hat meine
familie hatte grüne augen und man nannte
uns deshalb kreuzritter basterds weil
man nicht gewohnt war dass ägypter grüne
augen hatten und man hat eine legende
aus dem mittelalter dass alle grünen
eugen ägypten eigentlich die deren ur
großmutter wurden von den kreuzrittern
damals vergewaltigt und ich habe gesehen
wie muslimische kinder christliche
kinder und bedrohliche kinder
rassistisch angreifen die ganze zeit als
ich nach deutschland kam
da kam ich auch mit meiner unsicherheit
mit der prophezeiung meines vaters dass
ich hier ist nicht schaffen werde dass
die deutschen kaltblütig sind und da saß
ich eines tages in münchen in der u-bahn
und oder s-bahn glaube ich und da kam
ein bedrucken betrunkener fußballfan auf
mich zu und hat gleich scheiß ausländer
was machst du hier
und ich wurde fast in den bogen in den
boden versuche ich war fast in den boden
versunken ich hatte angst richtig
existenzielle angst und plötzlich
erinnerte ich mich nicht nur an das was
mein vater gesagt hat sondern was meine
großmutter gesagt hatte
sie hat gesagt es gibt keine fremde
menschen es gibt nur menschen mit denen
wir uns noch nicht unterhalten habe und
dann da fiel mir sofort was ein
da trug er die schale von vom
fußballverein 1860 münchen
und dann habe ich mir gesagt ich kam
nach deutschland weil ich ein 60er
fanden
und dann war da eher wie entwaffnet und
dann saß er neben mir heute gesagt wie
wir jetzt wohl kommst du musst aus
ägypten kennen die ägypter überhaupt die
60er hat er gesagt na ja sagt ja
natürlich alle gibt da keinen sex ist
eine gute mannschaft sie sind die
wirklichen vertreter von münchen nicht
die bayerischen millionär und plötzlich
war der mann kein rassist mehr und war
fast ein freund und das hat mich zur
reflektion gebracht weil er an rassist
oder vielleicht ein mensch der genau so
wie ich viele schwere koffer durch das
leben mit schleppt
ich kenne seine geschichte nicht und ich
will ihn nicht beurteilen ich konnte aus
ihm einen freundlichen menschen machen
dann ist er bestimmt gern das ist und
alle anderen erfahrungen die ich alles
rassismus verbuchen konnte zum beispiel
ich rufe an
in braunschweig da will ich eine wohnung
haben ich arbeite in am institut dort
rufen mein name ist abdul samad ich will
ihre wohnung besichtigen und da hat
einer tatsächlich gesagt nein ich
vermiete meine wohnung nie an tunesien
und dann habe gesagt ja ich bin aber
kein hellseher und dann sagt das ist mir
egal
sie haben mir die wohnung
kaputt gemacht und balkon kaputt gemacht
und dann habe ich mich gefragt sind wie
die leute wirklich rassisten oder haben
sie schlechte erfahrungen gemacht und
haben sie für allgemein hat was auch
schlecht ist aber ich stecke nicht immer
rassismus dahinter wenn ein arbeitgeber
eine muslimische frau mit kopftuch nicht
so ein zum gespräch ein lebt weil sie
ein kopftuch trägt
wenn er das macht weil sie muslimin ist
dann ist das kulturelle rassismus aber
wenn er das macht weil die letzte
mitarbeiter mit kopftuch die er hatte
die menschen die hand nicht gegeben
hatte oder nicht auf dienstreise gehen
wollte oder probleme wegen
essgewohnheiten gemacht hatte
dann kann ich schon auch verstehen wenn
ein arbeitgeber sagt lieber nämlich
abstand davon
trotzdem haben wir rassismus in
deutschland wir müssen darüber reden
aber nicht in form eines tribunals wo
eine gruppe von vornherein alles theater
und die andere als opfer geld was ich
sehr interessant finde ist ja diese
geschichte mit dem 60er schal wie sie
damit ja ich sag mit sehr viel
selbstvertrauen und und geschickt diese
situation bewältigt haben das ist
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht jedem gegeben
aber was ich sehr interessant findet
dass sie auch sagen umgekehrt auf der
seite derjenigen die migranten
diskriminieren das ist nicht dünkel und
überheblichkeit sondern denen mangelt es
an selbstvertrauen wie das das ist der
schlüssel
das ist der schlüssel eigentlich
rassismus gibt es seitdem ist menschen
auf diesem planeten gibt vermutlich mit
der ersten begegnung von homo sapiens
und neandertaler mit dieser archaischen
sitten bildung da gelten andere immer
alles fein da andere war immer eine
bedrohung und die sippen die archos 7
bildung ging nach dem prinzip wir gegen
die anderen oder wer mit uns nicht mit
uns ist ist gegen uns so gesehen ist
rassismus ursprünglich aus einem gefühl
der angst und nicht aus einem
überlegenheitsgefühl entstanden und
heute ist es auch so kommt von
unsicherheit angst auch undefinierte
unbewusste ängste und
deshalb ist das ist rassismus auch kein
privileg des weißen mannes es gibt auch
schwarze rassisten es gibt auch
muslimische rassisten es gibt sogar in
muslimischer rassismus schwarze muslime
leiden darunter die ganze zeit von den
weißen muslimen oder nicht schwarzen
muslimen diskriminiert zu werden
deshalb sollte man auf die sachebene
bleiben und nicht den begriff rassismus
immer ideologisch verengen so dass nur
da weiß man rassist sein kann
was mich immer wieder überrascht hat
sind die die die vorschläge die sie
machen wie man das überwinden könnte sie
sagen zb deutschland braucht eine
leitkultur das müssen sie jetzt glaube
ich schon erklären wie das helfen könnte
rassismus zu überwinden wir haben viele
leitkultur in bereits in deutschland wir
haben eine linksliberale reitkunst
leitkultur eine rechtskonservative
leitkultur eine islamische leitkultur
und ein islamistische leitkultur eine
türkische nationalistische leitkultur
die leben alle in deutschland und haben
geltung aber wir haben angst vor eine
gesamtdeutsche leitkultur die nicht
unterschiede zelebriert sondern das
gemeinsame sucht ich meine wertekanon
das was uns alle verbindet
unser haltung zur freiheit unserer
haltung zur gleichberechtigung unserer
haltung solidarität
das kann man nicht nur aus dem
grundgesetz abgewinnen das grundgesetz
regelt die beziehung zwischen staat und
bürgern aber wir brauchen einen
gesellschaftsvertrag zwischen bürgern
selbst wie wir zu diesem land stehen und
welche spielregeln für uns alle gelten
das ist mein konzept von leitkultur kein
rechtskonservative oder nationalistische
wie ist es ihnen den persönlich gelungen
sich in deutschland zu integrieren so
weit dass sie sogar sagen ich liebe
dieses land individualismus war der weg
ich habe gelernt mich mit mit keiner
ethnie oder religion oder
gedanke zu über überall über zu
identifizieren
individualismus und das ist einer der
größten leistungen eigentlich der
aufklärung dass sie uns in die lage
versetzt hat uns von unserer kultur ein
stück distanzieren zu können unser
herkunft damit wir davon nicht
vereinnahmt werden
individualismus ermöglicht die
emanzipation sowohl von der fremd
zuschreibung der mehrheitsgesellschaft
als auch von den kulturellen gefängnis
in der eigenen minderheit und wenn man
frei ist wenn man seine gedanken besetzt
selbst besetzt und nicht davon besessen
ist oder besetzt ist dann kann man
eigentlich mit den anderen mit
deutschland sehr gut zurecht finden
integration beginnt mit emanzipation von
den von der eigenen last
integration ist der weg zur freiheit und
nicht der weg zu einer ethnischen oder
religiösen vereinnahmung wenn sie sagen
deutschland macht es den migranten
besonders schwer hier heimisch zu werden
weil wir so viel probleme mit uns selber
haben das ist einer der großteil eines
der größten probleme
ich muss selbstbewusstsein um gäste
einzuladen
ich kann nicht gedeckt seien und die
arme für andere öffnen
trotzdem deutschland ist in den letzten
6 26 jahren wo ich hier gelebt habe ich
viel offener geworden alles sich nach
deutschland kam habe ich nur drei
ausländer im fernsehen gesehen roberto
blanco vicky leandros und rudi carrell
heute ist die medienlandschaft voll von
menschen schwarzen türkische stimmig dem
arabisch stämmigen und deutschland lernt
und versucht sich zu verbessern und
deshalb für die finde ich diese anklagen
gegen rassismus manchmal so dermaßen
deplatziert so dass wenn man wenn sie
mich nach meiner herkunft fragen dann
gelten sie nach dieser engführung des
begriff rassismus nach dieser
identifiziert als rassist und das ist
unfair
sie haben interesse an mich sie wollen
sich mit mir austauschen
warum verbuche ich das sofort alles
rassismus dann baue ich zwischen mir und
ihnen geistige ideologische
gesellschaftliche und psychologische
mauer die das zusammenleben erschweren
deshalb halte ich identitätspolitik
eigentlich für gefährlich für das
zusammenleben das war phoenix persönlich
heute mit hamed abdel-samad herzlichen
dank und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]